cory booker was elected to the senate in
2013 after serving as mayor of Newark
New Jersey for more than seven years and
senator Booker is with us now at the
table we should mention that Gayle is
good friends with the senator and has
supported him in the past great to have
you at the table
I'd like to still friends I don't want
to spend too much time talking about the
president but to really go against him
you have to get the nomination right and
you're adding your name to a growing
list of Democrats yes run for president
yes
Kamala Harris who Leanne Castro
Elizabeth Warren what do you bring to
the table that differential intercept
you yourself from them well I have a
very unique political path effective
Wall Street Journal said I'm only the
21st American ever to go straight from
being a mayor of a big city to being a
senator and all my life from the time I
got out of law school I have been
running toward some of the toughest
problems and people said couldn't be
solved from taking on slumlords to
beating them to being mayor of a big
city during a recession when the economy
was falling out but yet we brought about
Newark New Jersey's biggest economic
development period creating thousands of
jobs opportunity improving our schools
so actually managing something running
it through crisis and getting to
Washington and still being able to bring
people together to solve problems like
criminal justice reform or getting
investments in low-income areas all
around around the country I want to get
back to the president for a second
though Cory because he says that I know
him
he seems to imply that he knows
something about you or has something on
you what do you think this means well I
think every American knows about being
underestimated to mean or just put down
and it's something I faced all my
political career having in Newark going
up against the Machine and so look I
history of our country is a history of
people under estimating this nation and
we doing impossible things and so we
don't need a president that's gonna put
down people or divide people this is
really one of those times in American
history I think we need a revival of
civic grace and bringing people together
and that's gonna be one of the major
themes of my campaign how do you
reviving civil great it sounds great
yeah but a lot of Democrats say we are
past that time in politics this is not a
let's all reason together and that the
nominee for the party needs
to be the kind of person who can operate
in that environment well clearly again
my career has been fighting and
overcoming very difficult political
opposition but we live in a country
right now where we have a common pain
whether you're Republican or Democrat
from medical care to working full-time
jobs and still being below the poverty
line we have so much common pain in
America but what we've lost is that
sense of common purpose and so more than
ever we need a leadership that's gonna
remind people that we have a common
urgency in this country we have to find
ways of putting indivisible back in this
one nation let me ask you a specific
question about an issue you support
Medicare for all you say we need to have
a common purpose how many Republican
votes in the Senate are you gonna get
for a Medicare for all most people would
say the number you're gonna get is zero
and unless you get rid of the filibuster
it's not gonna pass even if you have fit
well this is where I disagree I've gone
across this country sat with you know
Republican farmers with independents
everybody agrees that the United States
of America we should have never have
somebody who does not get access to care
because they can't afford it this idea
that health care is a right is popular
on both sides of the aisle now there's
many Senate partly why not just
strengthen Obamacare why do you have to
go all the way to Medicare for all but
again this is what I'm saying first of
all a lot of people use that term and
there's differentiation about what they
what they actually believe I know
there's pathways that are supported by
the majority of Americans that massively
expand access to health care and lower
the costs and that's what we need to be
focused on where is that common ground
chicken in every pot is very popular as
well how much it would Medicare for all
cost so know a couple things first of
all it's quickly people know how much it
would cost but again right now we know
even the CBO says if you lower Medicare
to allow 50 year olds to get into it you
can actually save they not only save the
government money but you can lower
premiums for all Americans and this is
the thing we're not talking directly to
issues that can expand access to care
and create a four billion to say that if
Democrats are having an honest
conversation while they are promising
what sounds good and and it should be a
universal right that people have access
to health care but if it's twenty and
thirty billion dollars over ten years no
one's having that discussion about how
their that will be paid and Nora I'm
having that discussion and I'm shown in
my records
time in the Senate people told me what I
got to the Senate you could not take on
mass incarceration oh it sounds really
good to end mass incarceration working
across the aisle we got a bill done in
the last Congress under this president
that actually started the first attack
on mass incarceration
what my career has shown from people
giving up on Newark New Jersey to
getting major things done in Washington
is that when you bring people together
when you fight to find that common
ground you can get things done that make
a real difference I know you've
campaigned with him and it seems the
more he talks the worse it gets you have
called for him to step down would you
personally call him and say maybe is the
time what are your thoughts now that's
not where he talks it keeps chant your
story keep streaming
yeah so it's unfortunate this is drawing
up a painful part of our past and he
should step down and start his road to
redemption being governor of a state is
not an entitlement I believe in the
ideas of redemption we should not be
judged by the lowest points in our in
our past but the reality is this is
hurtful painful to betrayal a public
trust he should step out of that that
position and begin to try to someone who
knows him do you think you should call
him and say that I know a lot
I have called publicly for him to resign
I've joined a chorus of their senators I
talked to local leaders there in the
state I think that he will fail in what
he's sworn oath to do which is to serve
the people of his state I do not think
he has the capacity to serve Virginia
right now he should recognize that this
is not about him this is about the
what's in the best what's in the best
interest of the Commonwealth and he
should step away from that job senator
Booker we were we're just getting
started on there I hope you will come
back so we can have a more fruitful
discussion about all the other issues
too that I know that you have dug into
in the Senate and will as president if I
don't come back Gail will not talk
[Laughter]